are you ready to go yes I'm doing all
right ladies and gentlemen welcome back
to your favorite podcast you know the
name
[Music]
all right mr. singer Mike Jamie now he's
offering to the guests let me see what
you got yeah that was y'all I was
wanting to do this and I messed it up
it's that whoo
dude I love that and that's really I
want to another take of that kids it's
earlier my play-doh what we'll do we'll
try to get it the end yeah to finish it
all right man yeah all right yeah you're
loud like me so you don't have to you
could pull it back a little bit you know
you know it takes a minute to warm your
voice oh yeah all right
well ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
podcast my longtime friend mr. Jamie
Kennedy whoa how are you it's good to
see you you know what's funny is let me
tell you when I first met you
Patterson's yeah it's actually right
down the street yeah no it's not there
anymore know what it was called but
Patterson's was one of these little
[ __ ] coffee shops and back in those
days in the like 90s we had to do open
mics mm-hmm you know and this just the
crazy thing about it is like that was
when I first started I was in my early
20s and I was just going to open mics
and stuff like that and I remember back
like you were sleeping on couches and
early night early 90s and you were like
doing your thing I remember seeing you I
remember seeing Jim Gaffigan I remember
seeing like a bunch of people like this
at just like you know Zach Galifianakis
all these caring Shepherds yeah man all
these people doing open mics and then I
stopped for like eight years and then
when I came back into it you're a [ __ ]
movie star you became the nerdy white
guy that was doing all the like you were
the computer tech movies I was like that
I was like the the goofy best friend but
in a lot like the third best friend or
something no you were always like it was
a hot guy yeah it was like you were like
that dude yeah caller you know what I
mean like yeah I'd always always want to
tech I was early dude that's crazy so I
was driving here and I got a little emo
cuz that was the spot yeah and you I
remember you coming in and you were
killing right away no dude
I was killing right away your want you
my Tula
whoa there it is getting it huh um bro
you were you were like just do you know
like you do you know like this you know
like you're one of my favorites
I appreciate another you're saying that
no you are no but I you made you laugh
like crazy you know do you let me ask
you this though just like not gonna be
an arrogant or anything but do you think
that is the reason that is is because as
a straight white guy and then I go up
with my goofy demeanor but I still I say
some really biting things is there a
party that's like damn I wish I could
say that yeah but also I love that
because you're a performer yeah you
don't I mean you are this you are when
people say what they're supposed to do
you're not supposed to do anything but
what you're doing wrong you are born
stop it no to be a comic you know this
is like I talk about this privately
notice tell me more about me this is you
have a point of view you're a character
your look you're your ability to act out
you seeing everything but dude you are
but that's what else could you be doing
I know you are it it's perfect you know
as funny is like the way you're saying
it it's like borderline like a
backhanded compliment how note it's only
because like I have a there's like a
plumbing issue am i up in my building
like something's going on where the
next-door neighbor is getting leaks in
their place right so then they came up
to check my toilet and my bat my manager
the manager the building he comes in he
goes yeah something's going on your
toilet seems to be loose I mean that kid
oh you're a big guy so you just call me
fat in my place is the same kind of
thing you're like like you're going like
look at you you're funny
no you're like I was the nerdy guy in
the nineties you were still it was like
you know so how about love how do you
think your journey has been I mean cuz
you you know you went from being like
this like you were open my comic you
were trying to be a comic and then not
that it happened fast but you didn't
really do you feel like you got a chance
to establish yourself as a comic before
you were thrusted into Hollywood it's a
great question and it was very it's I
gotta take a minute man take a minute
you got time uh it's such a good
question see I was struggling I struggle
for about seven years
yeah you know which is would you be like
financially or yeah financially Oh Cody
broke and also as a performer so I
started out as a actor and a comic but
what does that mean yeah you just out
there trying to matter it was basically
whoever would give you a job if it was
for comedy you were like I'm a comic
yeah acting you're like so true like I
can't tell people in love it's like it
wasn't like I had this journey I was
like a student of the game people are
like oh you're funny do stand-up you
know yeah do theater whatever yeah and
so I was doing that and then you know I
couldn't get anything but a lot all of
my acting jobs the big early ones came
out of comedy comedy right and it was I
don't know how people feel it is not but
the game is so different now but you
would do comedy because hey man that's a
good showcase people will notice you
right you can act you can dance whatever
you characters and those are back in the
day when we were doing like live sketch
shows totally yeah totally like that's
so that internet has removed that yes
like the Internet's like people go
people don't go can I start a sketch
group unless I was in a sketch who
called the suckling pigs I think I
remember them you remember oh my god I
remember that I don't even remember
everybody that was in the group it's
that stare terrible of me right now I
feel like what you're trying to remember
my fifth grade you know who was in your
fifth grade class I don't remember
everybody that was in the damn thing but
like we were terrible you know I mean
yeah but we did like shall we we found
little theaters in Hollywood likes you
know 14 cedar
we reduced joes and it was like but
nobody does that anymore because now
it's all about getting people together
okay who's gonna film let's get to lie
just gonna sound guy yes about putting
[ __ ] on YouTube yeah it's it's it's I
love it keep going that question that's
like yeah keep going it's no it's I what
I I was a lot of my jobs came out of
that factory like I would go and wait I
did all that waiting waiting waiting
waiting we me and then I got started
getting two-minute spots late at night
and that's how I got my agent you know
and started stuff so I started getting
like a little after a lot of auditions
it's a long process I started getting
commercial than the commercial there a
TV audition and I got a guest spot and
so but then when I started getting
movies it was out the gate and they were
what was the first I forgot what the
first big very first the I didn't
independent but the very first one the
right after that was Romeo and Juliet
right which was like you know it was a
good it was out of the gate and so I had
so I was really busy for I think I
stopped for about three years I was
doing enemy of the state yes in
Baltimore when I was one that was one of
your roles and I was I was in the harbor
yeah I was totally a tech role and it
was like getting paid well and you're in
your trailer a lot yeah and I saw a
little Club in Baltimore down by the
harbor I know what it was and it said
Dave Chapelle and it was in a little
Club uh-huh and he has been do it he was
already in Blue Streak it was a Nutty
Professor he had already been doing a
ton of movies he was already kind of
famous big-time Men in Tights besides in
the comedy and TV he was already doing a
lot of movies yeah how many things local
so I saw it and then I don't know where
I was I asked him one time like later on
I'm like you know I saw he's like yeah
man you gotta like write bits in your
trailer yeah cuz I was like focusing on
like the movies and then he I was like I
could just start writing bits again in
my trailer okay
I'd have to ask you a question about
what you're saying right now when you
started doing the movies so you're in
the movies was there a part of you that
was lie
okay so comedies done that got me hot
look go ahead but I'm saying comedies
done because it's like you do comedy
because you want to do this what I'm
doing now you like what I need to do
stand-up anymore I'm a movie star mm-hmm
so there was but then that's the moment
I feel like you're saying that you were
like I don't know I still want to do
comedy there's two moments that that is
that moment and I was kind of still
getting pulled back in but at the time I
maybe had 12 minutes I'm serious I had
enough I had a cup
[Laughter]
I did a couple of TV guest spots I had
two two fives and I had like two minutes
left over so that was the high and
they're like doing an impression but
like four minutes getting into it yeah
so two things with this I got to meet
people Bob Saget Craig shoemaker
different people Rick Overton who let me
middle for them and get to do 15 minutes
so I was enough so I work with establish
headliners that was when I started going
back into it but to answer the other
question yes and what was what you just
said it was Sinbad I did Sinbad he had
vibe member vibe yes and I did ride for
like 20 seconds and it was a good show
and I was went on their promote like
scream 2 or something yeah I was doing
my first headlining spot in a club
somewhere outside of Boston deep down
the freeway and they said yeah we don't
he's got 20 minutes but people love them
so it was like a small room and they
would let me do the whole week in an
hour and I bought like four openers
right till I had it and I promoted it
and it Sinbad's like you're doing
stand-up he's like he's like that is so
cool cuz he said the same thing about
yes I had that whole thing of yo I did
this it was this blow up and stand up
get a TV show become a movie star sit
back now yeah some of the biggest stars
in the world Kevin Hart he'll he'll do
a movie and he'll do a guess but he'll
do a youtube show at 2 o'clock at 3
o'clock he's done for more episodes or
something
4 o'clock you does something else it's
like he's an anomaly but you do you got
to do everything every it's so it's
right yeah it used to be now it's
everywhere yeah also too it's like it's
like you these some of the biggest stars
we know personally don't even do like
three of those things right but there
you know it's like it's like Rogen you
know he his podcast is so large like if
he didn't want to do anything else you
don't have to yeah you know there's so
many people like that like Chris D'Elia
yes so big now with the podcast and
everything and traveling around he's in
Carnegie Hall yeah you don't mean but it
still finds time to like do some movies
but for some it's funny how Hollywood
now is a pay cut I'm not doing stand-up
right because III still used to end up
to pay bills you know these guys are
like stand-up is like you know they go
hey you went to a TV show and these guys
are like well it's I say this now the
money is different but it's real yeah so
so imagine this so coming up what you
said everything you're saying is we
would do that to get what I call the
institutional money yeah so you would
get it my you know scream you know was
you know I made scale plus ten right
right to significantly more but now I
say you get what you earn because I
could go to a college and make a lot of
money but now colleges you know kind of
dried up and but now because people can
do their followings their fans are real
to see them yeah and there is no like
[ __ ] like you know you might get a
flat fee and you might deliver you might
not now these everyone you mentioned is
beyond have such a rabid fan base yeah
it's great
it's awesome yeah thank you but I'm just
I'm bringing it up is like this it's
different from when we started she
wasn't thinking about how I thought it
was like how else cuz I wanna keep it's
so different
yeah isn't it amazingly different so so
different it's cool that cuz you know
how it was
you know how it is well you know it was
weird for me because like I stopped and
so then stopping at a that error I know
you didn't I don't know I want to talk
about it because I know I talked about
starting back up you know as an older
person at thirty you know starting back
up it was like you know now I'm like I
know what to do I got to go to the open
mics I gotta like I have to you know
build up my reputation with the comics I
have to like cultivate relationships it
was just like I just was more savvy me
that I mean the biggest thing people
don't realize to do if I had to give
anybody advice it's like when I say the
words cultivate relationships
it means like a plant you have to water
it and you're not gonna see growth right
away yeah it's gonna take time because
so many people are like what can you do
for me you know and even if the thought
process is like even if I see you and
I'm like oh man Jamie Kennedy alright
let me see I want to get to know that
guy because of whatever my intentions
are I know that I need to go about that
in our CENTAC genuine way so my thing
might be like yo what's up and we start
talk one time at the club next time I
see them I'll be like hey man you know
it was good to talk to you again and
boom and then it's like you know why
don't we go get some cup you know to me
it's like you gotta take your time and
actually build a connection with
somebody next thing you know you have a
friend that you didn't even realize you
had yeah or you or you or coming at
somebody in a genuine way that they're
gonna be like alright I know where
you're coming from I respect what your
your hustle or whatever it is like that
cuz so many people now they just want to
like you know hit you on a DM and they
think you're now you're coming to my
wedding or something dude I will ask you
how much do you feel the business has
changed in the sense of it's much more
of a community now do you think it's a
community big time how so I would walk
well I mean this is me though I have
such respect for the game in people like
I would walk in The Improv in the early
90s and I would see Seinfeld and I would
like go to the corner and look I never
went near anybody yeah you know you
would see Seinfeld you see Sandler you'd
see Bruce fine you see you know Shawn
Wayans you would see
unknown you see me you see you know June
mell be all everybody different people
trying to get in and I felt like there
were not imposed with just hierarchies
at people this is headliners this is
middles that's famous these TV but now
everybody because of social media
connects I mean I people hit me up that
are open my curse people hit me up that
I'm fans of people I don't know that
like me don't know so I
what's more except it's more to do
podcast I mean you get big little let's
just don't you think people look chiller
now it's like there there's always been
enough room to eat but it was harder
because everyone's auditioning for not
that one spot I know on his home the
triple on the three networks yeah was it
was I would go I would meet me Gary Owen
I remember I would do all these
showcases remember back then was I know
tons of showcases Sherri Shepherd
like we were all okay who's gonna get a
development deal so it'll do that any no
but it was it was you know everybody was
cool but it was definitely like you know
I can't get my good five well I think if
we could have a social media discussion
for sure I mean I think social mean I
think it's more of a community you tell
me no but I think that like you're okay
because first of all like in terms of
like you being like one away from your
fans I mean I I think it's kind of cool
how people just can directly hit you up
and be like you know yes hey man you
know it's like you know good and bad I
mean like yeah you know like I met my
girlfriend on Instagram you know I mean
and it was just like one of those things
where she was a fan of I'm dying up here
she slid him you know she slid into DMS
you know but no no cuz just she didn't
message me first she did it slick you
know so she like friended me and liked
three of my pictures and when you're hot
like she is that's a sliding to be yes
for somebody like me you know you know
if you're like you know it's like you
know it's like so then I was like when I
see that I'm like there
that was a translation it was born like
a picture you and your dog you're like
oh yeah again at the same time though
it's like it's so funny that that's such
a male mentality yeah it's like I had I
think the me to movement has made me
like like oh let me take a step back
like just because a girl says oh just
because a girl likes your picture men
trans that translate that is oh you mean
she told me to scold man the male
translation is like weird in our head so
we've had to take a little step back and
reevaluate how creepy we've been been
but you know cuz social media is so but
I just get back to it I think that one
like musicians musicians athletes actors
I think they all want to be the other
thing I think comedy has the least
amount of respect from people but at the
same time people admire it greatly so
like what I find is like you ever do
this this is a weird thing I do this
sometimes I go to my Twitter but I go to
verified mmm-hmm followers and I just
want to see who's following me and
sometimes it's weird to see like oh the
tide in for this team and like you know
it's like oh this news anchor from
such-and-such and then you start to see
that maybe they'll send you a tweet or
something and you know it's like oh man
a huge fan of the podcast or like loved
your loved workaholics or like so it's
amazing the type of people that's what
the Internet has done yeah so and so now
it's a comedy community very much so
like we are we're able to like hey
what's up Chris Rock yeah what's up
whoever yeah you know I mean like I've I
remember I wouldn't shoot my I mean you
get one shot with Chris Rock that's a
huge shot dude I'm telling I was talked
about this already because I had his
brother on had Tony rock on but like the
one that one day I was it was Chris
Rock's birthday mm-hmm and I went to his
Instagram so I was gonna just put happy
birthday whatever and he was following
me and I wasn't following him and I was
like
we'll be ready for the room yeah so then
I was like unfounded then I just like
you know send him a message happy
birthday thanks man and I was like oh
[ __ ] this is so different
like it's so different and uncomfortable
to be like well he gave me a great
compliment a at the Comedy Store he just
I just got offstage and he came walking
out the O R and he came right to me like
it was funny he started talking to me
and I was looking at I was just like I'm
having a conversation with this dude who
is like one of my idols you know it's
really hard like let you know Eddie
Murphy's coming back to the comedy store
I just have you seen you know I just
want to see him walking around the
hallways I get like Chris Rock now no 7
he'll just be in the hallway you know
what I mean like the other days Seinfeld
was there with Sebastian and they're
just talking with Neal Brennan in the
hallway you know and people are just
walking by you know eager to me nobody
rolled up on them that's the kind of
place it is now yeah it's a kind of
place where you're like you know you're
just walking down the hallway it's like
oh you know just yeah but even regular
people so I think that the touch to your
point there is more of uh I think we're
more comfortable but I don't necessarily
think there's a Brotherhood because I
still think there's a hierarchy of
people I still think it's like the high
school cafeteria so oh the cool
podcasters you know the theme the
Netflix specials people and like oh
those are the guys over there does the
open mic road or guys and there's like
there is all that but I think people are
pretty cool I mean I'm in my own I don't
know what I'm in my own it's like you
know you're with like Pauly Shore I mean
like people like were our own entity
yeah right but it is it's it is but
everybody's cool with everybody I think
it's good I'm glad you feel that way I
always try to go in and go out but maybe
that's my I have like when I was in high
school and I was playing basketball you
know I'm the kind of guy need enemies
you know what I mean I just I I need
anyway are you good with the rock yo
yeah man I was skinny backing out
under 70 pounds I was all League at my
high school in LA yeah yeah weird la
that's really yeah which was Moscow but
I was like really yeah but it was like
basketball I treated my comedy career
like I treated when I was playing
basketball if people told me I couldn't
do it I was gonna show you that I could
do it yeah so that's just why that was
my mentality for everything so when I
was trying to get into comedy it was
this kind of thing like come on man you
are you you think here that for whatever
and I was like okay you don't think I'm
funny all right
so I always had that in me to like
that's what pushed me to this point you
know but there's a part of that though
that could be negative there's a part of
that could be like you don't sit and
enjoy things like what you're saying
like you see a Brotherhood and I don't
see that and it's um it's a weird thing
but go on but let me well cuz I am like
I said maybe I'm an outside observer or
whatever but I probably a thing when
people see me they go that's Jamie
Kennedy like I'm a whatever I am right
yeah and look it there are just it is
the New York Yankees every night I mean
there is 1012 bashers every night in the
oh are people that are selling five ten
thousand tickets at night when 15-minute
spots yeah that's crazy
and it's every love that I'm right in
the middle of the line I know and people
are all doing good so and uh I don't
know i when i was there when i see
people are like you know they're
complementary to each other they wait so
I don't see why oh that's one see this
is my problem back in the day if there
were eight people auditioning for a
guest spot on Conan you better believe
like you know no one's talking to each
other yeah I think I still think there's
a little bit of that I think there's a
little bit of like you know this
weirdness you know but like I've no I'm
noticing like I think the field has been
leveled in terms of like popularity and
like you know why things are funny like
there's no like deli system anymore
where it's like okay if this person's
turn okay smart way so we say well
you're gonna say what's well because
it's like now like the plane feels level
there's so many ways for people to be
faced
yeah people to be known yeah so like
just nobody anymore that's like super
famous like it's that there are a few
like it's like Chappell yeah wherever
Chappell goes yeah and those dignitaries
of the game it's like the one percenters
yeah you never mean yeah but there
everybody down like nobody should be
bumping people nobody should be like
yeah you know me like that kind of [ __ ]
really pisses me off I never bump
anybody I know but it's like but I'm
saying no but why nobody should be able
to bump you know it's like you nobody
should be able to like you're not no
ones that you know what I'm at anymore
that's what it has changed there isn't
really any bumping and even people like
Chapelle will come to the Comedy Store
and he's very like particularly like
I'll come and go out to her let me go
lady that's way he goes oblate like if
you go to the Comedy Store and you're
there at like 12:30 a.m. you might see
Chappelle yeah I know I know the reason
what he'll do an hour in the reason was
he's like I'm not gonna bump the people
that are put in the time you know
whatever you know yeah these people that
are learning how to do it yeah you can
you can go after me but like he's very
you know particularly but some people
are still like you know what they're
[ __ ] like you know I got to go to
this other thing like what's the time I
was at the glass factory and Drew Carey
comes in you know uh uh and he it was I
have a Dru moment and he would and he
had like another spot at the I'm only
using him because it's gonna be for
everyone yeah it's a position yeah so
you know he's got to go to spot it that
there probably is I came they're like
what you wants to go ahead you cuz you
got another spot it to improv and my
thing is like if he's drew Carey the
other spot at the improv is gonna be
fine
- yeah yes like why does he need to go
now
mm-hmm in front of me because he could
do the same thing over there right so so
what the [ __ ] does it matter so I have
you know before me you know but I'm I
think about it is is it's [ __ ] he
can't talk to him no have you so we
tried to exact because it doesn't has
something to do with him okay it has to
do with the concept of somebody that
famous coming in and [ __ ] and being
like hey you know I got this other spot
I really need to get you know you don't
[ __ ] you don't got to get to it
cuz your your your the fact that you
know in that right now now see I'm
worried if drew ceases
I would if I knew him better I would
tell him the same thing yeah because it
has nothing to do with him but what if
he had two spots and then he had his
mother's gown what if he had a personal
he can come into the Laugh Factory at
any time it'd be like can I go up right
now that he could do that at this spot
that he's supposedly missing
no I all I'm saying is like the whole
concept is [ __ ] my thing is I just
come and go I want can I go now yeah
these excuses I don't need you like oh I
got it
no no just be like I'm true caring I
want to go next yeah and I'll be that I
respect more than giving me the you know
but it yes that is probably an older
school mentality know what and that's
why and this is the reason why I was
like this this is - this probably
happened to him along yeah I get it
I'm not this isn't personal to him no
yeah this isn't a personal to him this
is about like how the business has
changed yes so I feel like now that
because I feel like if people did that
now they blog about it be like well you
know I know but even just don't think
people are necessarily dude there's a
few people that are still like popping
in like Bill burr pop saying all the
time saying but it's like dignity but
mild things like you live in LA you
could call in and be like you could get
on the line up
it could be oh he's coming in even if
you say you gonna block off an hour for
the guy 30 minutes 20 or whatever how
much the time is whoever the person is
bill burr Drew Carey Eddie Murphy James
ship I don't care who it is
[ __ ] you live in the city mm-hmm
call it a club mm-hmm have you assisted
call the club such as such is gonna come
in as okay if he goes up at 10:00 then
you tell all the comics who are doing
spots all over the city running around
who gotta be on time for [ __ ] they know
all right just dudes coming in for 40
minutes cool all right let me give you a
counterpoint to that what happens if you
let people bump you they love you and
then you know they're like what's up
Eric that doesn't work like that I know
but you never know
no no but I go yo let's talk about this
video you know this is like this is like
Jay Davis used to do this to me all the
time
or like these people that run shows in
the city yeah they would be like oh yeah
come you know you're closing the show
today I'm but it'd be a show that it'd
be like Chris D'Elia
Jamie Kennedy all these people on the
show you know I'd be like well I'm not
closing the show you know cause like you
say what's a compliment I said no no the
compliment is when would you like to go
up that's the compliment yeah so he
stopped doing that okay cuz closing the
show just means like I'm just a funny
guy and I'm a strong comic so I I'm a
closer show I'm strong but the real
spots are the ones in the middle we're
all the like people are with the crowds
hot and you know the mean everybody that
meets on the bow I gotta make a broth
with it you know I'm just saying it's
like it's like it's a weird mentality of
like I'm just like just be real about
I'm just that kind of guy I get it if
you're gonna say to me hey I want these
more famous guys to go in the middle of
the show because the crowds hot
you're like say that to me yeah because
you're being transparent yeah that's all
I feel you know what I feel like when
people want they bump I have been bumped
I've been a bumped a lot in the last few
years not a lot but a good amount five
times ten times oh I always let it
happen because I feel like I've I don't
allow people they're gonna be like oh
you can't anymore
do you know name me that's right now but
I feel like Weezer because I know what's
up with your boundaries maybe maybe I
got issue but I just
I do feel blaming yourself not blaming
myself but I just feel like I have to
play ball because I get true because I
am a whatever I am and people just say
[ __ ] whether they know it or not your
name and so I'm not like what I'm not a
human anymore I'm like you know bounce
I'm like bounce
you know fabric softener you don't I
mean like it's there it does the job
sometimes it's hot
sometimes a coal you forget about it do
you feel this way because do you feel
this way because of like your your you
know you had on you had a arise you had
a hot moment yeah you know and then it's
like as all things you know things taper
off they go like how they go yeah now
you're in your career and now you're
back to stand up you know and so do you
feel like like you have something to
prove still at this point
big-time not that I ever left stand up
but you tell me I didn't start coming
back in town again all the time until
2015 that's what I'm saying you weren't
around but but was it but let me just
cuz it was anybody wasn't everybody on
the road no man no this is what I'm
saying
you were one of these people that's like
you so do I see why you felt the way you
felt then because it's like there are
people who are like actors mm-hmm you
know there's people who are like actors
people that went on that people that
like used to do stand-up or dabbled in
stand-up but then they took off on
sitcoms and all this kind of stuff yeah
and then it kind of just coming around
Jeff Garlin's like that mmm he's now
coming around doing stand-up but it's
like you're not part of the Brotherhood
then and I'm strictly speaking like The
Comedy Store for instance because it was
a process to get into the Comedy Store
you know so you had to like get past
then you had to do these belly room
spots then you had to like become a paid
regular and then you do an hour spots so
there was just like rite of passage that
went on for a certain generation of
comics same time that like so when
somebody came that was like oh the movie
stars here you know now he wants to do
stand-up you know it's like you know who
the [ __ ] is this guy trying to come back
you know what I mean so then so there
was a little bit of that say 10 years
ago you know 5 to 10 years ago
you know it's different now because a
new person has taken over Mitzi's dead
and that sort of era of how to do that
it's it's different now mm-hmm there's
still a there's still a process but
there was a transition to that process
you know well first of all everybody and
their mothers doing comedy right second
and podcast second of all you know that
I did stand-up from the get-go I know
that but but I know but how do people
don't know everybody's history no no we
don't carry around a dossier no but what
I'm saying is is what to me I got hot
then I was on the road
forever yeah and I was getting great
offers colleges clubs I still play a lot
I almost every other weekend I know but
that's different but the clubs in town
were showcases right and I fill in 2015
all the sudden you see an open mic er
and then you see Chris Rock and
everybody who is everybody was a
commingling you agree
I mean we're that from 2010 to 2015
yeah I would do a spot here at Skylar's
show spot here you know people would
call me but I was always on the road or
you know I know but that's what I'm
saying so you became you you were a road
comment yeah you know you were yeah
that's true you know you were you're a
celebrity comic yeah exactly
yes you were so same with celebrity
comics so what's different which was I
know and you know what's interesting
about you but you have a feeling about
it though I could tell that you have
like this part of you that was like hey
[ __ ] I was sleeping on couches
doing open mics a cop I need you to know
I need you to say that yeah but no I
don't know what people think of me I
know people dig me but I'm cool but it's
like I did come up with people like
Sherri Shepherd and you and I remember
back in 92 or 93 going to the store
waiting you know walking around and
Rogan wouldn't come out of the main room
I'd see him in the hallway
probably 94 and Martin Lawrence would be
doing a spot in like Poston so it was
James Stevens the third we do it an hour
and so I was around all this different
times this was different then yeah
and so I what I started when Melissa
McQueen was like you got a you know
people's Booker start to call him and go
yo you want to do a spot when they do a
spot right now and I realized that I
have to be in town a because people just
don't know where the [ __ ] you been
even though you're killing it in Iowa
right unless you're on TV
B you know you can do a casino show I
make you know play 800 people but no one
knows where the [ __ ] you're at and see
just to be part of the community yeah
and also did it is like I was sometimes
go up and I'm like yo look at just
[ __ ] line up me and I gotta follow
this person in that person I'm like why
do I want to do this when I could just
walk out to my fans
and get my balls licked and then I get
it and but now I'm glad I'm doing it
because it makes me better
I don't it's uncomfortable it's very
humbling it's oh yeah it's uncomfortable
it's very you got a dude I'm in LA this
is how hard it is and you know this and
I'm [ __ ] got two auditions
maybe you know uh I had a meeting with a
big producer I got a [ __ ] 8 page
dialogue but I gotta get ready for my 12
minutes spot and a killer lineup at the
improv I got a deliverer it's harder
than going on the road yeah but that's
why I say what that's what get some
bling it keeps you into it yeah it's
very humbly and it's like I feel like a
lot of people are like that and I have
no problem with like this is what you
what you didn't do what you did wasn't
wrong I'm just saying this is the result
when it comes to the Brotherhood in the
city yeah you know that it's just like
when I go to New York nobody [ __ ]
knows me in New York mm-hmm you don't
mean I'm not in at the cellar and like
these kind of places you know I I tried
to send the lady a message I've talked
with her she was like oh yeah you know
I've been sitting in a table with her
with other comics and she's like I like
you give me a message when you're in
town but it never happens I've been in
town I sent her a message about doing
the club in Vegas and it was like
nothing no response it's like are you
thinking yourself we talked about so I
can headline every other place in the
country I'm not one of the main guys at
The Comedy Store I go up in the main
room not or last night it was that's not
it was uh Marc Maron me Joe Rogan okay
that was the lineup last night so I'm
like so and then you you think that I'm
not worthy of you that's not you think
about in your head you guys you know but
that's just what happens you got to be a
part of a brotherhood yeah so if I I
need to go to New York more if I want to
be in New York and like be around under
your comments need to be in that New
York scene cuz I'm not famous enough to
be like where people go where people who
see me and go oh oh you're that guy cool
and you have these friends go up so
that's all that it is there's a lot of
people like that like Jo koy it was like
you he he's he's just out here selling
out the forum yeah he's right now
thousand large you're selling out
stadiums
you know when he comes to town there's a
level of new people and stuff that might
be like well we're where's
man who's that he's selling out Manila
exactly but you what I want to say is
this though is that uh he's made a good
time is that I do you feel like this
like the store is its own animal oh yeah
for sure
and every other club in town was always
more like showcase showcase no I
disagree like I well know I feel like
there's communities there but you pop in
pop out the stores I don't think so I
always use the clubs because I would
hang around sometimes but not much like
I never got this when comics allows
gonna hang around to get a spot I'm like
no man go home write a joke work on your
impression whatever right so I never
hung anywhere I just pop in and pop out
and maybe that might be to an issue of
mine because when you were saying about
cultivating relationships I never did
that unless it happened naturally I was
always about to work and moving keep
moving but that work process is the same
work you have to put into a friendship
to me yeah CENTAC I know I know but it
should happen naturally you should be
sitting at a coffee shop laughing go
into yeah you know but it's just lat but
it's just you know you go it's just when
you get older to you start to go how
many relationships do I need in my life
y'all you know cuz I'm already watching
a TV show that council as a relationship
you know every Wednesday so it's like I
mean I get it I get what you're saying
but it's like you know that's what we do
things like this you know yeah it's like
you know yeah and like not anybody can
start a podcast and be like yo Jamie my
podcast
yeah so you're coming on your podcast
because of our pre-existing you know
talks and like seeing each other you
know what I mean so that's this is the
Brotherhood you're talking about right
now
yeah that's what I'm seeing yeah you
know I'm recognizing that like I was
able to start a podcast that people
aren't coming on it because of my big
numbers they're coming on it because of
me they respect you so I'm like okay so
that's the Brotherhood right there yeah
you know so I agree with you on that and
it's like like I said you didn't do
anything wrong
I'm just I'm just pointing out to you
the feelings that you feel when you're
trying to come back that those are valid
feelings too from the people around you
but don't don't take that as like you
know don't let don't let your issues of
you know oh I want to you know please
people or I want to
like make sure I'm doing it right all
that stuff you gotta break through that
and just you know do you people like you
yeah no you know I I do I just
active I always try to be super
respectful yeah because you know there
is a hierarchy yeah but this like but
that's like man I know I'm my thing and
it's like a weird but it's like weird
like that hierarchy isn't it's nuanced
dude I don't know and I love this when
you use that word you use nuance that so
many things good to me too movement all
this yes it's it's it is but I feel like
you know like I just shot a special I'm
waiting to see where it goes I mean it's
literally in the hands and Netflix you
know let's see it's in the hands of Hulu
which are really hard you know yeah yeah
yeah or it can end up on YouTube you
know what I mean which will be a larger
audience than all of those place yeah
but there is you know this like you said
there's boxes of things as New York
there's Netflix as people that do Comedy
Central so I know what you're saying and
I just try to be you know I just try to
be cool I do
everything you're saying is I agree with
but it's just like I'm not gonna come in
and be like yo [ __ ] you no no of course
not
but like I say there's there's still a
little bit of like you don't want to be
you don't want to come across as the you
know you know though doing a [ __ ] yeah
like the weak gazelle like one day I was
mad at John Mulaney
okay uh-huh he's more top names he's on
the lineup
okay so it's like I'm supposed to go up
he's going up then his manager or agent
or something's like yeah I want him to
go up next you know hmm
and it came to me like I was like you
know what I was mad about it I wanted
Mulaney to tell me yeah you wanted to
[ __ ] comics yes come over to be like
oh man can I go before you sure you know
15 minutes it's fine but to be treated
like you know I don't matter that's the
kind of [ __ ] they're like that [ __ ]
pisses me off
did you talk to him no I haven't even
seen him in I don't know I'm
like that to be like that you know so
say whoever he's so big you want to hand
me and all this kind of stuff so it's
like this that kind of feeling where
you're just like well you know you let
it go yeah you do tell you I mean I'm
with you I take things personally all
right but no might not be spot might not
be person of course it's not personal
but it's not personal but it still
happened yeah
look if I step on your foot by accident
I still should apologize yeah 100%
yeah he might have been thinking of it
but yeah you're right kind of things
that like you still have to deal with
though you just like you know you so
what I'm saying to myself is I'm mad
that I should have said something
I should just want you mouths words like
you're mankinis can you tell me next
time but I didn't do that yeah what
would what happens if that you did that
and what if that wasn't what if that was
awkward it would it would have been
awkward yeah who cares you know I were
like you know yeah I mean you know we're
on this is how the lineup works you know
I know that you know but it's like I
would I would have appreciate but see
that's just what I'm saying is you're
going I feel that you're being like I'd
rather not be confrontational by no I am
but it's like pick your battles Chameli
Hey did I go up to him no pick you out
you're doing it now on the Internet this
is not no I'm just saying I'm really I'm
retelling we're talking about we're
talking about right now about when you
have issues yes how you a confront
things how yes and I'm I'm just pointing
out that like you know that's a moment
that it was like should I've confronted
should I have not have you know it was
like I felt this way I taking the too
personal was like I'm just analyzing the
situation of like you know what do you
do in certain situations and it's like
you know you're sitting there like what
do you do see here the thing is it bumps
you wants listen that guy's got a lot
going on right now
it ain't a pound no no no I know huh
okay this not about the bump it's a
process you know me like it's one thing
for somebody to kind of care how big
they are okay how big they are just like
especially if you're on the line up
you're just one in the lineup your your
honor it's not like it's not like
he walked in the room with his agent and
they said yo we want to put this dude up
next oh oh I thought it was that no
[ __ ] he was on the lineup it
said Eric Griffin Jonathan wasn't a
Peter loud
no he was on the line up already so he
went from here only because his agent
didn't want to sit around for one more
comic you don't mean it's that kind of
feeling you get what I'm saying yes it
ain't even about him no I'm just I'm not
this ain't even like if you're taking
this is like I'm doing it no it ain't
about him it's about like this whole
process yeah you know it just made me
feel a certain way where I'm like damn
who's this agent did he just you know I
mean like like that's what I'm saying is
different about the store that's really
taking back to that conversation is what
I'm talking about it's like back in the
day there was a thing you know all these
heavy hitters were already on the lineup
and they were like how they were [ __ ]
with each other was doing a lot of time
mm-hmm you know [ __ ] up the store
yeah with their nonsense yeah so now
it's like this so now we're we feel like
we're in a good place in that all these
heavy hitters are coming in but then you
have some moments where you're like yo
man what what what the [ __ ] you doing
yeah yeah that's all yeah cuz there is
such a beautiful respect and and
everyone does keep to their time and
it's just boom yeah yeah
the agents man that's [ __ ] no but
always the most annoying yeah I'm sayin
so you had this like that was just a
Hollywood moment yeah you know I felt
like I got highly wooded you feel it a
place that's not like that anymore cuz
everybody's so respectful right Road
upstate yeah that's what I'm saying it
was like this this ain't supposed to
happen here yes you're saying everyone's
respectful be respectful don't be a
[ __ ]
but don't step and it's like so what do
you do this like oh I'm saying there's
no right or wrong answer in that
situation so in the moment I'm like part
of me there's 50 I'm 50/50 fit the other
part of me part of me wanted to be like
you know hey man next time he just can
you ask me so it's not like this [ __ ]
with the agent you know a uni or or you
just do what I did you just don't do
anything
here's the same with it it'll be like
fun
look at this [ __ ] here's what I would
say this is what I was just finished one
a sport I wasn't even mad at him yeah I
was mad at the people at the Comedy
Store who were just kind of like oh you
know oh I don't know what's good you
know like y'all don't respect the
process either you know it's like
everybody bitched out everybody bitched
out you know I mean like everybody was a
[ __ ] in this situation so I was like
you know I mean even John because he
left it up to the agent the agent was
the one that was like good
I'm the King in here you know to mean
something okay so everybody was like oh
wow I don't had no support nothing
nobody thought to say hey you know I was
just like oh man it's just one of those
moments man
it irks me because it was so nuanced see
now I feel that is what I would have
done I would have you would have done
[ __ ] here's the deal hold on man you
don't know that I wouldn't it wouldn't
have been a big deal to me I know it's a
midweek let me let me say my partner it
was a midweek spot I don't know when the
[ __ ] it was it wouldn't even matter
weekend you're there all the time
you're a [ __ ] staple you're one of
the [ __ ] pillars you were on this
show that was [ __ ] about the store
uh-huh okay so to do went ahead of you
who cares if he comes next time and
you're there and he's like again then
you might have to say hey bro
Jamie what's that did I say so no you
did it you know you did it but we're
talking about it you and me it irks you
though
I don't even think he should have worked
you know I guess but there wasn't like
before the tonight that's why I'm saying
like what I was talking about earlier
I feel whatever you feel but I just saw
saying what I was talking about earlier
is like I need to have more of a feeling
of brother this is my issues okay
because like here's an example okay one
day put you this scenario but I'm gonna
say this and I'm that type of dude that
thinks yo man
dank cuz I'd be like this yo Eric thank
you bro whatever you need I woulda been
like that I think I go maybe that I
could work nobody came up to me I know a
small point but I've been bumped and
people just [ __ ] on me and other times
I've been with people and they've been
like yo man I appreciate that they
appreciate so I feel like I could build
a relationship what happened
you know like okay so this is let me
give you a scenario a little looked over
at moment at that moment yeah but it's
ridiculous to feel that way again this
is my own see your perspective I like
you're saying it's a brotherhood and it
is no big deal I'm trying to get to that
point okay I can help but here's another
here's a situation this is to carry
which which speaks to again it wasn't
about him I know I'm paranoid though see
I'll tell you about that later
what paranoid because I've been in this
business I see people cry over the
little this [ __ ] everybody's a [ __ ] so
here's here's an example of like thought
process go okay Adam II get thirsty
understood the Booker you know he comes
up to me right before him what to go
onstage in the main room and he says his
words he goes hey um do you do you a
stuff tonight
mmm you know so I okay he could he says
that to you what's your first thought I
maybe I let him down a spot ago or see
interesting like I got a light deliver
this is so interesting how this the
answer to that question says a lot about
our own psyche see you are someone who
is like always thinking about I gotta
make sure I'm doing my eye was instantly
mad like you don't tell me do my a [ __ ]
all my [ __ ] is a [ __ ] like how dare you
I was in a green room [ __ ] pacing
around like [ __ ] him
you know I was so mad uh you know what
it was what probably somebody there to
see you that was a very power the head
of Netflix was in the audience
Wow what's his name Bezos no well
they're all the same
Ted Sarandon Saran dose mom ted serios
is an audience so but to my credit I did
do my a [ __ ] okay Adam walks up to me
he's like God I was great he goes Ted
was in the crowd and he was just he was
just go he was really loving it and then
I thought to myself let's check this out
my first thought is who cares did Ted
Danson
that's the only topic I could think of
but my point about it is I shouldn't
have immediately went to something dark
and negative I want to talk to you about
that that's what it was so like in all
these situations I'm talking about it's
like I'm I love I love talking about
principles cuz that's what this is about
so the Drew Carey situation and an about
drew Carey it's the principle of it it's
the principle of being life just be
straight up with me man you don't want
wait I'm cool
you drew Carey you're famous mm-hmm
Family Feud do you you don't mean
whatever the price is right I get it
he's I love him you know so I got it but
I wanted to be like don't tell me about
your other spot bro cuz he said it to me
he was like yeah I get his other spot
you might not go hit it's like really
you gotta get to your other spot so it
was about that on that situation I'm
alone on that go ahead okay the net and
then and then the situation with Mulaney
same thing you know why go negative it's
like his his ages there they're
obviously he's working on something
important obviously because it was like
if a big deal for him to be you know
whatever he was working on it didn't
have to be a big deal you know what I
mean
so I didn't like the principle of it was
like yo man there's a brotherhood here
come you know come talk to me but that's
that's the only thing that I care about
I don't care about the bumping I don't
care about none of that [ __ ] I just care
that like yo give me some respect that
I'm on the line up with you we're one
away from each other so give me some
respect you know so that's what that was
but it did it don't have to be a big
deal you know and then the thing with
him come up to me talking about hey do
your a [ __ ] that was for my benefit was
loving exactly it was beauty and in fact
I was loving because we didn't want to
scare you and put pressure on you and
make sure that I'm seen in a light that
he knows I could be in yes how much more
positive and fruitful and like you know
that is so what I'm trying to do this
year my new year's resolution for 2020
is to like take a step back and not
everything is not everyone's against you
not everyone is know how to get you now
but see I I'm aim I still feel that way
because that's what drove me to be too
to just what's wrong greatness in ball
I'm trying to be great but hold on
but going now you go she said so much
there's a lot to unpack there
I'm package that madam thing was just
beautiful yeah and he did you a super
solid exactly now when I go back to
those two things but one of the first
times early my career the factory I want
to see me for finally getting a showcase
spot who comes in and bums me
Dane Cook Rodney oh I mean if you look
at bump by the way completely different
error I'll hold on but I wanted to just
keep watching her yes it is 8 for his
new Tonight Show destroyed I actually
did ok the first two minutes doing that
ok and now who the [ __ ] is this guy with
the twisted hat and all that [ __ ] but it
was like dude I was there to be seen I
couldn't breathe but and obviously so it
depends on what your thing is but if
people for there are people like not a
lot of people bother me if they want me
right but and I've done a lot would you
not say there are people that should
just have carte blanche though in my
opinion you know what I mean Dru's he's
an OG dude he don't bother me so if he
asked me himself
ok so that's good yeah but you wanted
him to go y'all dude if when you were
saying that there I took a little
umbrage to that why because I think
you're right but I think he could just
and you wanted him to explain yo dude
I'm drew Carey no no he didn't have to
say it like that he didn't like hey go
go next yeah he's trying to help you
again he's just trying ok he's just
trying to be cool he's trying to be like
he's gonna make a man I got the sense
but but but you just want him to go yo
bro no he's not play not like that ok
well he wanted to be so goddamn specific
Damon Wayans one time came up to me he
said when you're going up I said I think
I'm going up next he goes like this
[Laughter]
young but um I respect that wait uh dude
yeah but you okay so you didn't like the
way he did it but I there's probably no
ill
there was no ill will and there's no ill
will for me either I'm just pointing out
but I got a funny story on that was uh
damage Jesus goddamn it Jesus God why am
I losing the name um a living color
Shawn Wayans Marlon Wayans one of my
favorite Robert Townsend no no uh Tommy
Tommy Davidson why my brain flavored
Alan Grier David today should be dumping
anybody no wait that's my boy I'm
sending him this clip [ __ ] you Alan
don't show you no scholars 93 people let
us gather but and it was like David Alan
Grier sitting there talking and he's
like yo man he's like doing characters
and voices he's like I'm just gonna go
up there you know just talk a little bit
he's like I don't want to work that hard
and he's like let me go next I'm like
yeah go for it he goes up there hello I
was dying I'm like dude you did a
performance I gotta follow that he was
killing me I was dying laughing because
that but that was but here's what I'm
saying I see something in you I don't
know whether this became therapy but I
like it it's always therapy but here's
the deal you you know what's so
interesting about you your persona is so
lovable and I'm not I'm telling you this
this is because I say what I feel man
okay you are so lovable and so [ __ ]
funny but all that inside is a hurt
little boy yeah everybody but that's
well no hold off I know we all have
reasons not to do it but what I'm saying
is and what's so funny about you is
multiple things but you go into those
dark places where you look like this
lovable sweet guy who can razor-sharp
claws which is beautiful but you do
sometimes I agree with you I know what
you're saying and you do feel looked
over and I because and you are so
talented it's so funny and everybody
knows who the [ __ ] you are
party you might just be like yo man I'm
putting in this work forever [ __ ] give
me the right respect yeah and I think
you're it's valid but i but i do think
it is there as part of [ __ ] that is
Hollywood no I don't know and I know we
all eat yeah yeah that's but that's what
it is
what I'm saying is like how you deal
with that yeah we'll help your own I
think it's good that you're getting out
psyche you're giving it out and getting
the anger out but that's what happened I
don't I wouldn't get in everybody's
faces unless they're actively
disrespecting which you're not I haven't
no no no this is this is my platform
jealous get all these things out talk
about it but like you know it's like but
that's how begin when I play basketball
that's how I play basketball so I was
angry yeah
so I played I played angry so I like
doing stand-up angry I like having like
a thing on my shoulder and I go through
the business like that and it's not
always good yeah because no because it
was like like the night the night I
booked the denied that's the reason why
I got on I'm dying up here was because
Jim Carrey was in in the in the car with
the whole producers right but even
though he was there I'm about to go on
stage and an Amiga goes hey Jim Carrey's
here and my first thought was like is
this [ __ ] pumping me going
through my head [ __ ] doing here
pumping people 300 million dollars in
the bank he already made it he trying to
come over here [ __ ] with some
[ __ ] jokes he's [ __ ] there's all
these are other things done
right all things go through my head man
but here's the thing when I went on
stage I had that energy in me yeah I
[ __ ] I destroyed the place yeah I got
an audition the next day I was on the
show in three weeks
yeah so there's part of me that's like
you know but you know what this is like
I don't mean it's right though because
this is like people that drink too much
and they drink on stage and that's when
they're the funniest and they think
we'll look how funny I mean when I drink
[ __ ] you that ain't that ain't you don't
have to do that then you're really not
funny yeah yeah you know I mean yeah so
so that's something that I'm trying to
like you know these are moments I'm
thinking about you know this really all
like it is sort of therapeutic you know
because I got saying I know what may
come across like oh I'm talking about
these things the talk [ __ ] about those
people no I'm talking [ __ ] about me I'm
sure this is what was going on in that
moment and then like you get yourself in
a situation where you don't even know
how to react or how to deal with it you
know so like the what is one [ __ ]
easy the easiest way to deal with it is
the way like I deal with it on my own I
carry the anger with me and I just go
deal with it
I would Adam told me that when he was
like do you a stuff yeah you know like I
didn't I didn't I knew not to in that
moment be like [ __ ] you talk about to my
a stuff yeah what's your problem I
didn't do that yeah I had it in me I
walked away and did it you know that's
what I'm saying yeah so like for
instance with with Mulaney
it was the same it was like the same
kind of thing it was like to all this
[ __ ] is going on and you know the door
did the people in the Oh are there
they're going like well you know I don't
know and then everybody's like yeah
sorry buddy you know that kind of thing
I'm like nobody so I was mad about the
process of how we going on but I didn't
act on it yeah you know what I mean yeah
and that's like I just went up and did
my thing you I ate you ate it yeah I
just went up and I ate it then I went on
stage and did my thing you know it's
like like cuz my thing I'm mad about
with the agent like you would have been
entertained you should have saw me yeah
I don't feel like there's anybody that
could go up and then I'm gonna go up
after and they're gonna be like that guy
wasn't as good is just that I
that's the confidence I'm feeling myself
I'm gonna go before you after you like
none of y'all are that funny
none of us are but you know but it's
like you have to have that sort of like
strength and delusion and
confidence in your abilities you know
what I'm saying so there's a lot of
people walking around peacocking with
their podcast and they're like you know
they're the fame versus you know talent
man ability like they're not always the
same mm-hmm yes let this [ __ ]
out here doing podcast stuff but I'll
stand by being like you ain't as funny
as me sorry you know what I mean so but
that don't mean anything
mm-hmm but because I come from an old
error where we thought we knew that if
you made it that was the funniest guy
Yeah right that's the arrow we came from
yes so we came from an era where there
was no data line there was no skipping
the line the people that were eating
where people that work funny and put in
the time those days are gone but I'm
saying you write Rises let me rephrase
yes the cream will rise to the top but
what the problem is when you get up
there there's a lot of trash there's a
boil milk so I agree oh I think that
like yeah you will you'll make your way
through with talent and you know and but
I'm just saying it's like we could see
because of social media because of all
the networks because of entertainment is
so visible we could see everyone see
back in the day the only people we saw
were the ones that made it but what we
probably didn't know that there was a
lot of people out there selling out in
Toledo you know they were doing it thing
but we just didn't know so now
everything is visible so we're seeing
people who are like you know a church a
cake in a hundred thousand a show
someplace or there's like you know you
don't I mean so now I'm again you're
trying to flip your thought process and
I'm trying to be like you know what you
know people are there because they they
did their they made it in their way yeah
you know so and now everything is
everything
yes I never like when I see somebody on
stage and like I'm not a fan of their
comedy and a lot of my friends I would
say half the people at the Comedy Store
I don't watch them I can't stand their
comedy right but I respect what's going
on really and you're friends with that
yeah your friends I don't think you're
very funny you know I mean but like when
you're on stage
when they're on stage
I get I get what they're doing it's just
not my brand
well I don't I don't I don't like the
jokes oh I don't like how they tell
jokes oh I don't like but I respect like
these crowd loves what they're doing all
right I don't have are you kidding me no
I'm people have I think you're at
podcasters going by the way because no
no no but I'm saying like but that you
know that's I'm talking about like you
know it's like when you're when you're a
female comic and you have a certain
perspective you know your crowds coming
for you
you know actually right I don't
particularly see to me from the outside
of observer please you are just a
naturally funny person but that doesn't
necessarily mean but to me it's just you
if you put you in a room you put you on
a stage what you want to say you don't
know murder I'm gonna tell you what am I
one of my problems and I'm working on
now just trying to get more help I'm
trying to be healthier healthy
physically yeah okay because I'm the
type of fat gasps look at this this is
some real [ __ ] hear me I'm the type of
fat that you look at Matt you go that's
lazy I'm lazy fat if you look at me and
you go damn I'll focus your workouts
like he needs to lose that gut what's
going on you been [ __ ] late 40s you
know so it's hard but I recognize that
as opposed to somebody who's just a fat
[ __ ] and you just like you know
like Bruce Bruce is just a fat
[ __ ] and they love him for that
you know what I mean but this is the
kind of fat works like you shouldn't be
fast meaning you're on the couch playing
so many of you I guess the look it has
you know our hub in it you know hold on
you eat a lot of carbs no I'm not
anymore I'm trying not to go Kido that's
me and my girl doing this thing she's
like we're not gonna eat
bread anymore right okay so wait the
lazy so you're gonna get less fat I'm
trying to and it's already working I
feel you know but it's like when you're
when you're this size and it's like you
know it's like I got a I got a I don't
know what I still don't have a dad bod
but I should I could look healthier so I
think that it works against me because
you're like I want him for that part but
I don't know if the part calls for you
know do we want a fat like I'm not fat
enough to be the fat guy yo dad bond or
big Tony right in there area is lazy Wow
so and there's something you don't get
comments from people who are just like
rude but I see them but I don't care you
know people like you 2/3 but one guy
said he was like this is an audition
I'll talk about it on the podcast
comments later there was fun guys it was
funny was like well if you worked if you
exercise as much as you worked on this
podcast those kind of things don't get
to me because it's like I feel this way
like I'm all about like this whole black
body shaming and like body positivity no
you all y'all can go [ __ ] yourselves all
[ __ ] I don't know what I'm allowed
to say on that you can see ya what see I
mean it's all [ __ ] to me cuz I'm
about like I know why I'm this way I
like hamburgers and pizza and I like to
eat late and I'm like exercising is hard
and I'm busy and it's like like people
you should have said people should
accept who they are and we should
celebrate everybody but you can't you
can't comment if somebody is yelling
dude here right on that verge of
diabetes you know I mean I always say
this to obesity obesity is a killer yeah
you know what I mean and it's like just
because this would have just feel weird
about it just because it's hard to lose
weight society is gone it's so hard so
let's just accept you know what I mean
let's just it what if we did that for
comedy it's too hard to do comedy so
high be fun let me just do it mediocre
Lee yeah you know I mean oh you know
what it's caught me so hard I'm just
gonna do knock knock
you know yeah see that's what I'm saying
so I don't want to be knock-knock fat
you gotta make that a joke oh this guy
you're always thinking like a comic why
it's true bro wait I want to go back to
what we were saying no I here's where my
brain goes you saw by the way you know
what I love about you right now
what you're so aware that you're on a
podcast it's so funny is that good or
bad
so like oh this is gonna be out in the
world are we having a good time I just
want you to be comfortable no I want to
talk about that job if you say something
that you feel like no I said this and I
don't want that out no I didn't say
anything bad
yes I'm gonna cut that part out where he
said no just kidding
I [ __ ] I was gonna say now no I'm not
I'm here now okay
well yeah is that well you spill the tea
yeah this is the world we were - let me
ask you I want to ask you but here's the
thing and I love that yeah you're right
maybe I can learn this yeah I'm just cuz
I do spill the tea sometimes you got yes
yes do you gotta make it bulletproof and
I think you do just own your part of it
like in all these situations I've said
I'm owning the part that like a lot of
it is my perception you I know but
here's what I think you know here's me
me people want to watch the part that he
say some [ __ ] explanation mm [ __ ] but my
thing is like I don't care about that
because yeah you know what I still have
a platform it's in a one time thing
let's say that happens yeah then you can
gonna come back in my pockets and be
like let me explain this again like I
already spent you know yeah and then the
people that were talking [ __ ] they don't
come back because they're like cuz they
know what they did yeah yeah they know
what they did yeah they know they took
[ __ ] out of context yeah they put it out
there but they don't have the balls to
like stand by their convictions yeah you
know
see that's the thing it's like you
everybody is awesome it's like I have
people people you know how people are
now people come up people take
everything out of context yeah every
[ __ ] thing but you also can't be a
person that is so worried no I'm not I
lean on me finish
oh did you talk the whole time with him
with Griffin go ahead no no I'm just
said you don't wanna be president takes
everything out of context that worries
about it no I agree no you watch what
you say I don't and I do I never do that
on stage I'm let you talk oh I never did
it no I never did it on stage but I do
know I never did on stage but I do six
more things but I do do that sometimes
but no it is like you know I don't know
everybody's so [ __ ] you know I know
right I mean everybody is so it's like
who wants to deal with it
it's basically good you go what's the
lesser of two evils it's just to be like
all right let me know it's not getting
it I'm standing by my [ __ ] and when I do
the goose [ __ ] that people get pissed
off at I'm standing by it because the
joke always comes first and I'm you're
talking something earlier that made me
think about this it's like I had this
interview earlier this week and people
are saying yo you worried about you know
more people is it harder to do comedy
now and I say no it's actually better
because it's more polarizing because
people there are more people going
against it saying you can't say this
right those people are always there
we just never heard their voices because
they didn't have the ability to tweet
Facebook and Instagram
they were always out there in the weeds
now we can hear them but they're being
so annoying to the true comedy fan that
the true comedy fan is like [ __ ] so it's
even more voracious don't you feel I
agree too but it also makes it we have
to be more thoughtful I think that this
this culture is making like comics shine
the cream is gonna start to last because
you have to be make sure that like this
I'm stealing this from Ricky Gervais
scuzz he said the jokes have to be
bulletproof yeah oh god that was
you know and I'm right sure was like I
was so like so I was so glad just I just
want you know but no in the way face by
the way billionaire by the way two years
ago I was talking about how you
shouldn't protest at reward shows on my
special but you know no I'm just saying
it's like no matter like we all got how
it works in Hollywood is whoever the
loudest most famous voice is gonna be
the one that people gonna be like oh my
god this is great yeah yeah yeah good I
mean like nobody else could talk about
hot pockets but that kind of thing so
it's like you know yeah but I mean I'm
like I totally but that's why I loved
what he was saying yeah I just like
right into these people's face it's like
but it wasn't even just to them those
people know who they are you know
billionaire corporations they know who
they are and they don't care cuz I got
billions of dollars it's the stupid
liberal elite Hollywood who think they
can like speak for us who he put in
their [ __ ] place in a beautiful way
beautiful hilarious way and [ __ ] they
couldn't even get it because he was
[ __ ] levels it was just layered upon
layer upon layer it's like it's like if
you're a kid he basically said if you're
on an Apple show yeah shut your [ __ ]
mouth because you're contributing to
oppression yeah if you're doing a tweet
how to not oppress people you're
tweeting from a device that oppresses
yes so it's like get out of my face you
know look that was great he did it it
was beyond I mean I just I've watched it
10 times yeah I know dude I watched a
few times so just to be like oh man to
have them just to have the like but he
said most of you have less schooling
they [ __ ] know well I mean look man
Tom Hanks is one of the goats and it's
like it was it was interesting because
he's he is only [ __ ] guy he came up
as one of the
these people what I what it interesting
that he I don't know was that it was at
the face of playing ball or was that the
face was he offended well I think that
was the face of was gonna play ball I
know but I think that that was like
that's what is when you feel me here
that's why I can't go off all the time
because I'm like in Hollywood but I
don't know what it's like this is taking
over Hollywood
which I love does that make sense it's
like people are tired people who tired
of the [ __ ] [ __ ] and I don't want
to hear that [ __ ] on your [ __ ] speech
but he said it was perfect I'm not gonna
listen to my congressman I'm not gonna
listen to somebody in Sag yeah but I
think there was like and I knew there
wasn't [ __ ] I think I think I felt I
almost felt like a comedy that moment
honey but I felt like a comedy like
shake up yeah I felt like it really felt
like cause it at a place that was
preaching to the choir it was like the
Pope talking to Catholics like yo we
need to stop acting [ __ ] stupid right
right and they were oh so I think cuz I
don't think because that's the problem
with award shows now is it's a lot of
preaching to the choir yes cuz
conservative people don't watch him
anymore
no this a bunch of liberals bloviating
about you know what's wrong with the
world
and then from there Bentley's further
president and then like the people that
are watching they're like you know you
know conservative Christians in the
middle of America are like you know we
like movies - hold on - not just
conservative Christians dudes in [ __ ]
Detroit no you know I mean come on
normal people bro yeah yeah I believe
I'm a pretty normal dude I'm in
Hollywood but I don't you be out there
and I listen to a cocktail waitresses
every week and what they really say yeah
what they do you know what you so right
it's like it's just the regular middle
class lower middle class you know
blue-collar people who have to listen to
like people except gold statues tell
them about what's wrong with the world
yeah like [ __ ] you're what's wrong with
the world yeah because you're [ __ ]
not in touch with the [ __ ] exactly
and it's like Ricky Gervais said he had
to be the guy the bloke that shouldn't
be there
they got the microphone and that's
exactly what he did but what he's but
again to reiterate it was one of the
most
bulletproof moments yeah like there's
like like if you're someone who doesn't
like him what can you say how does luck
how exactly we said how to [ __ ] in the
LA Times which I read in love give it a
review that they did I haven't even seen
their Oh reviewed they were like and
he's there he didn't need to listen to
him you know try to silence their voices
no he did it he was basically saying
you're [ __ ] you're full of [ __ ]
[ __ ] what you and I are talking about
right now is the hypocrisy that is
rampant just on the beginning thing on a
jet help the environment get the [ __ ]
off the jet and good on Spirit Airlines
carry one less luggage I mean that's
what he's saying yeah all like to me I
was like I don't think he was saying I'm
not trying to silence your voice not it
was like I'm just trying to remind you
that you're full of [ __ ] or full of [ __ ]
yeah you know all this [ __ ] when you go
up there and you're like on an Apple
show and you're you're gonna you're
gonna go there and be like I know this
looks wrong with the world let's be you
know I want to be on an Apple show he
wants to be on an Apple show [ __ ] I
want to be on a Redbox digital show I
would have a [ __ ] but here's the deal
it's like dude you just made me lose my
thought it's [ __ ] oh I did yeah hold
on you see it was what he was saying was
it it's just a hypocrisy it's like that
it's like this you can't do a joke about
though number one thing you can't do a
joke about right now is the trans
movement and it's like yo man but I do
yeah but it's like if you say one thing
you're transphobic to certain people and
it's like yo you got to stop with that
[ __ ] phobic Bobeck hope they tell you
what phobic is phobic is like being like
oh right you can't stand next to the
person how about company transsexuals we
work with transvestites but my comedy
store has had a world-famous I would say
transvestite been there since I before I
started I mean I grew up in Philly tons
of trans people of all different and
it's like don't be so don't be so comedy
phobic yeah that's what I say I have a
sick joke faux [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
somebody said humor
phobic yeah man it's like don't be so
humor phobic there should be a thing
yeah right it's like dude it so that's
the thing it's like that that's what
gets me a little weird like don't you
don't you that racism but but but sexism
and I mean but by the way because of
that feeling that you feel right now
what it is because of you having that
feeling right now at all like I know but
that's what makes us more thoughtful
about our jokes
ya know you gotta make this more bull
yeah we're to try to get there so glad
that's why I appreciate it all yeah so
I'm not like like to me when people say
they dislike the younger generation is
sensitive I don't think they're
sensitive I just think they're
ill-informed
I think that they don't read they don't
you know they everything's black and
white for like you know the woke
cultures things are black and white
because they don't know that there's a
nuance they don't they don't they're
just they're just not informed enough
about either side that's when people are
sensitive they just have a very
narrow-minded view of things and then
they you know they speak out loud about
things that they're just really not
involved hold on I gotta go counterpoint
today I actually think they are very
informed because everything is
everything and this is my boyfriend who
recognizes himself as a girl but he's
non-binary and I reckon so I believe
they're they're actually trying to let
everybody have a voice but what they're
saying is how dare you question my voice
does that make sense yeah but that's
people that are again but my thing is
like we everybody gets [ __ ] to it on
the subway I know but that's why I'm
saying if you're just informed about
your point yeah you are ill informed
yeah yeah yeah if you're only concerned
about your side you're ill informed yeah
that's the deci right so when people
come at jokes and they go like oh you
said a word so this means this how
ill-informed is that yeah like how like
close-minded that is to not see that
that's not the point of the what we're
saying right now yeah this is just how
you're taking it yeah and then your
voice is so loud that you're making it
out like you're right nobody's right or
wrong we just were just this is when I
tell a joke I'm having a conversation
with the crowd so now we have to just
make sure that our setups are more clear
the point is more clear that's what
beauty of a podcast yeah so I could you
know if I say something about someone
you clearly [ __ ] on her Kerry I cut your
part out I'm just gonna do a fake cut
that's when he started talking [ __ ] no
but I clearly feel like I clearly
defined what I what I'm talking about
how I feel my rock but that's how you
get to it like we got to it together -
by me saying I had a problem with this
and then as I end our conversation I'm
like well you know what well maybe I'm
overreacting how would I I wouldn't be
able to know that unless bounce it off
we have a back-and-forth of dialogue
yeah and these [ __ ] out here they don't
want to have a dialogue or phobic they
do not have I don't want to have a dial
yes that's why I said man there's two
types of people or what I would say in
this on stage there's people with a
sense of humor and then there's people
that aren't very intelligent exactly and
bro there ain't mainly informed that's
exactly what I'm saying and people
taking words literally yeah it's I would
use this as an example I use this as an
example if I'm on a freeway you're in a
car with me and it's jam-packed and I
say to you man there better be a severed
head up here yeah okay now what do I
mean you and me there better be
something super important a going on why
the traffic is like this yeah but these
dumb [ __ ] out here they want to be like
this he wants to cut people's health he
was he was I hate to be ona whose head
is it gonna be a black kid they want to
go in yeah you have missed the point
yeah yeah you've missed the point yeah
and that's what jokes see the thing
about jokes that make that this is the
hard part the unsaid words in the jokes
are oftentimes what make them really
funny yeah but called subtext subtext
yeah but what we have to do now we're
when subtext is taken out then it's just
like oh man
like I want your
to fire I want your neurons to like
Philly think and fill in the gaps yeah
you know but so we have to find more
thoughtful ways more like just be more
clear and that's the fun part about it
it's been fun to try to be able to take
on certain subjects yeah that's it for
us huh I don't know you know what I like
that I think we this I that's a good
closing closing the time here but now as
your voice warmed up because I know he
wants the second shot on a singing mic I
hated it you know you don't got to hold
it too close with the word yes so we
gonna do to get but before we leave I
just wanna say I want to thank my man
here mr. Jamie Kennedy is coming on the
podcast I'm gonna have all his
information below oh thank you
thank you for having me thanks for
coming on and I like that you just like
I really appreciate that you didn't even
hesitate
why would I well I mean something to do
you'd be surprised if you all do
did you I'm glad you thought of me that
I just pop up I do I have a list of
people that I want to ask you're on
you're on my short list yeah you know I
mean he's not doing [ __ ] it needs some
[Laughter]
are you busy we had at Jay Davis's party
we focus at the wine cellar yeah we had
like some good fun had a we were gonna
do a cop show but he wants the second
shot so again guys thanks again for
watching me from what Griffin makes you
subscribe and share you know what I mean
and I just I just want to thank you guys
for your support of your favorite
podcast you know the name
[Music]
alright let me see what you got this
time come on
[Music]
[Music]
just cut it all that I can sing but I
just was so nervous
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right see you guys next week please
that's harder on that bite